anders is here yeah now
i never do introductions everybody knows
you you're so famous that is true god
don't you you are very famous and
something really quick i'm going to say
that i think is important i always open
this podcast with yeah
oh you don't listen to it
i i
will get to it but i do watch the clips
on instagram yeah i've got a comment
button okay what about what do you have
some feedback on this i saw the bop pop
up and i was like did you do you guys
not do that anymore to intro the clips
and i said
thank you because at first it was like
pavlov like oh cool a moment watch
something funny this is something i
yes always something funny but then
after a while having like
i don't know six to eight posts a day
and i'm scrolling and by the way maybe i
shouldn't be on
instagram this much right the fact that
you haven't muted me is is shocking but
it's just like math bap
swipe just like i wouldn't watch six
people above or below you i just had to
it like destroyed your relationship with
your family members i have like uh
tennis risks
i was listening to uh whitney houston
has a song that she did it first
no but there's a remix with kyoto kyoto
some dj keep guessing
keep hate climbing yeah um uh and it's a
remix of higher love and it is kind of
my power song when i'm biking and really
need to like
blast it out
and um
uh
she goes
like
i'm such a bad singer it's like not even
funny yeah and i remember being like oh
she's saying bat-bap-bap and i was like
that's whitney houston
she did that 30 years ago right i'm like
i'm calling my lawyer i trademarked that
and i was like every time i hear it it
is shocking to me
it's a good time to go after her i think
so too yeah i feel like it's all time
that we acknowledge that whitney houston
was a thief
of mine
i didn't say that
just putting that out there okay so can
i just but wait real quick
because of the batbap
uh mainly dudes from workaholics we do
this is important and i told the
producers i go hey when we put out clips
put a little thing at the beginning that
lets everyone know this is our shit that
you're about to see and it's like a we
have like a news
theme kind of thing for the opening of
our podcast because this is important
love it so it's like
of like the news mm-hmm stole that from
you a sound cue sound cue a sound queue
and i still i guess i could have just
said all those things i could have said
yeah but
not no words but it's like
i'm giving you a warning you're about to
hear a shrill woman right
complain
you you can or like whatever this cue
means to you right
like here's the thing you have to hear
someone just
talk shit on whitney houston r.i.p
okay
just i'm stopping this lol train for one
sec we're doing a little timeout
we gotta talk about the cozies speaking
of timeouts oh i put myself in one yeah
in my violi outfit if you will wear
these clothes they must be cool
oh they are no they are very cool they
are even designed to look great in
everyday life they're not like just for
working out well here's the thing i if
you work out if i work out and get to it
great but i dress to work out all the
time right right yeah it's perfect it's
not like you're getting sweatpants like
you're not getting cheap sweatpants they
are an investment piece for your
happiness and for our listeners they are
offering 20 off your first purchase
a lot of sweat i'm seeing a lot of
people out there trying to do this like
exercise clothes and public thing it's
not working for you it's not working you
got to get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet at viori.com whitney these
are working v-u-o-r-i
these work not only will you receive 20
off your first purchase but enjoy free
shipping on any us orders over 75
dollars in free returns go to v-u-o-r-i
dot com whitney and discover the
versatility of yori clothing they're the
cutest don't be silly okay back to our
show let me just open with are we
friends
yeah
right
we go way back we do we don't see each
other very often sure we don't call each
other ever sure uh just got your number
sure
but there's something
here's the thing about you is that it
like you and i have been in kind of um
it's not concentric what is it when
you're like
concentric circles yeah but like when
you're next to each other but you're not
in the same group but we are strangers
we are like i'm the associates i'm
stalking you yeah what is it when you
follow a guy around you think is
attractive but he's been in a
relationship since he was 16 so you
can't be with him but you just follow
him home every day what's that called
concentric um i don't know what yeah i
what is that what is the we are in the
same um world are we not colleagues
what's another word enemies yes but
you're
i think for me as a stand-up like i
guess we never crossed paths as much
because you weren't doing stand-up at
the time when i started staying i never
did standing you never did standing well
i take that back i did three open mics
it went fine mm-hmm do you remember any
of your drugs well so the short story
behind why i did it was
i was the assistant at um one of the
assistants to the writers at real time
with bill maher i didn't know that yeah
and a lot of those guys did you do any
research i was just saying i googled you
a lot this weekend and so a lot of those
guys photos of your house for like two
and a half hours that's weird we'll talk
about that later um
those guys a lot of more stand-ups and i
was like you know what i gotta go do
stand-up to kind of like speak their
language because i was pitching jokes
and stuff and
um
so then when i did stand up i did a mix
of new rules
that i had written that had gotten
approved by like the head writer that he
was like i'll show this to bill this is
funny yeah and then bill was like i'm
not gonna put this on the show so like
funny but not
for bill uh right for bill maher or just
not written in a way that a stand-up
would say it
no they were written very well
i'm trying to help you out here yes so
anyway they they didn't make the show
but
the head writer was like this is good
enough for me to tell him or like show
him right so i go okay good so i was
doing those and then also just a little
like unscripted riffing um in front of
other stand-ups which is not
very fun but it was fine but i didn't
get that um
i didn't want it you really got to want
it if you're going to do stand-up right
and i was like not in love with the
experience i was like i'm not going to
break my neck trying to i'm just i'm
just curious because i think everyone no
matter what you do for a living should
you should do stand up at least once in
your life unfortunately most people's
first time is at their brother's wedding
and they end up just being offensive and
ruining ruining
the wedding right um but uh
i'm just curious like what do you
remember like emily did stand up twice i
did one do you want me to remember one
of the jokes oh just like a dude i i
remember um coming out to
um
genuine's pony it was something like
that no it was uh
it was it's a sample that's been used a
bunch dr dre
uh erica badu also sampled it but they
just i came out to that and i was like
i'm like uh you know people clap and i
go thank you thank you i'm not that cool
that is that song is cooler than i am
god that's a fucking cool song that's
the kind of song you wish played when
you open the fly of your pants just like
fucking
you know it was like it was just like it
would set the tone so you know that was
going to be the song i had they were
switching back and forth
and i was so you had a sound cue
yes
are we done should i go before we ruin
this that was perfect
um
but yeah so i was and then i got some
laughs from that and then i did like a a
new rule but i didn't say new rule i was
just
it was something about uh we need to
bring back fins on cars fins yeah cause
like they were just fucking sick and i
was like they're like
the tits of cars that's so funny right
okay thank you that's sofa or like the
ass implants of cars yes and then i kind
of like
overextend myself by being like
uh and this is more for bill than it
would be for me i was like and with
global warming we're gonna need fins on
our cars cause like
yeah the water's rising yeah we're gonna
need gills yeah yeah um you know so it's
like half funny half like real half like
for realsies right um
and that i think that's all i remember
though that's fine you only get two
minutes
but i'm fascinated by
when you're gonna decide to speak in
front of a bunch of people you're like
and as someone that you are
annoyingly
like i'm jealous of how you're funny
like all the time
constantly
i i pity your wife it's sick
it might be exhausting but it is like
you have the mind that like you can make
anything funny at all times so then when
you decide oh i'm gonna be funny for two
minutes what you select as sure does
that make sense yeah but i will say this
when i see you
you have so much energy that i'm like
it's go time let's do this let's have
fun and then like i'll see you in a
couple of years yeah yeah you're like
whitney's recovery
yeah no but like you're you're always
somebody who i'm like i want to be funny
for this person because you're so funny
that's very kind but that thank you but
almost like when you go to like a spin
class or something and you sit next to
someone you're like this person's pretty
crap i'm not cranky
the person that's like kind of your
enemy competition you kind of want to
impress them but also i think i get
really you're obsessed
but i also feel like i
uh what what just happened did you oh
you said i'm like got the poisoned one
oh yeah um oh did you give him the
roofed one by accident that was for
emily um when i have someone like you on
i get so excited because it's like two
puppies i feel like we're like puppies
that have never gotten to play at the
park
you know what i mean it's so exciting to
be able to just be like i know that
nothing's gonna hurt this person's
feelings
around and you're gonna like like make
fun of me and you're not worried about
my feelings and i'm not worried about
yourself and then on the drive home i'll
be like just go right into the other
side of traffic
everything she said was true
so because i i know
and also i disagree with you um about
i've listened to you on a bunch of
podcasts you are funny
you are so funny
in a way that is frustrating to me
and like can i just ask you like
did you know i know i've had to work
hard this is over me being f you're
funny in a way that is like does it and
i i don't know how to say this dude
what's your trauma man like what
happened um
that molested you it's a um well
it's a laundry list it's a laundry list
it's um i'm a youngest
okay of my family of three boys great
and they're like six and four years
younger than me or older than me they
ran trains on you got it and they ran
trains on me with
father sebastian um
and
manitoba which is how we got funny just
i just worked with him he's the best
great guy um so
dying for attention got it not getting
attention you know what i mean were you
this tall at a weirdly young age i was
six three when i was
i was ready to just go yeah when i was
four years old i could slam dunk
i was i was in a circus
the barnum bailey brothers
uh i was i was tall but i was like
appropriately tall okay like like there
was always like two
weirdly tall kids and i was just kind of
like tall cause guys that look like you
that are like handsome they're usually
not funny
uh i had bad teeth so i was like i was
born with an extra tooth in the middle
that is so funny so when i lost this
tooth which is fake when i lost this
tooth it grew in like sideways and the
dentist was like um
we're gonna do some x-rays and they
found out that i had another tooth in
the way up here that was making this
tooth growing kind of like cockeyed uh
cock toothed
that's weird um so like they pulled the
like
the hidden tooth out by the root and
then i just had like a gap here and a
gap here uh and i was super
self-conscious about that i never smiled
i still don't smile i don't think i
developed like the muscles to smile
um
so i developed other muscles
um but so then like it's one but like
and so by the way like i swam but like
that's not cool either you're like in a
speedo
uh i wanna talk about that in a second
hold on we have two sets of teeth during
our lifetime these are primary you have
the baby teeth and your adult teeth
people typically she had to google this
are you fat i'm just trying to no i know
i i had a friend in high school who had
an extra row of teeth above her teeth
right like two rows of charcusia
sharkesha
and emily this is the most she's ever
laughed in any podcast and it's starting
to get insulting um i'm going to accept
these cookies because i don't give a
fuck take my data you can have it um uh
is it called
mice so din's having an extra tooth mice
odins my signature whitney i have no
idea
i have no idea i'm trying to give you
free health care that's what this
podcast is that would be tired it's
estimated effect between point one five
and one point nine percent of the
general population uh-huh i mean and you
can't just come waltz in here and say i
had a tooth growing out of my nose and
just move on
it wasn't growing on my nose it was just
like um
impacted or whatever in the gums it was
just limited ingrown tooth yes there it
is was it supposed was it a tooth that
would have
never dropped
it would have never dropped
okay they would have just been kicking
it was it one of the 20 or was it
was extra it was a 24 you have 20 so
like when you're born some people born
with extra nipple or
whatever you had just an extra tooth
floating around
and it's and i'm surviving and this is
my favorite thing when you google the
exact cause of this is still unknown
like no one even bothered to do research
on this um it's possible that genetics
environmental factors and changes during
dental development may play a role so do
you switch dentists
oh my god did you grow up near a uranium
plant or
or it could be
because because as someone
who you know i was just born with it
whitney
maybe it's maybelline maybe it's
maybelline so i
used to work with i still do this um
charity called operation smile for clef
lips yeah i'm familiar yeah yeah so
they're saying it could never reached
out to me
never got that call
because you have cartoonishly good teeth
now these are fake
and why are those fake because giggy
died and i took the money from giggy
dying my grandma and i got fake teeth
and lasered eyes
when i was like
23 when i moved to l.a so your teeth
were wild before they were wild they
were just like not great you know you
could like squirt water really easily
through them kind of thing that was like
my calling card were they taken out
no they're like the they're on the rebar
oh yeah but they're under there yeah
yeah so these are like if you pull these
off it's just like
like
naked mole rat mouth
but wait what are they made out of
because if you're under a black light or
your teeth do they glow in the dark i
don't know do we because i found out
that there's a girl that i actually
don't get a black light on me there's a
girl that i should
come all over my face
um
right before i came here and it spilled
on the car because this guy in traffic
stopped and just auditioned for the new
marvel movie guys
really close that'd be amazing i just
went to an audition i think i got it and
then you do the black light and it's
just
no just a jackson polling painting on
your face what's up
were you auditioning for silver surfer
did you have makeup all over your face
but um it was a girlfriend of mine
in high school we went to like a like a
night roller skating party
and in under like the dark black light
like she had one tooth that was like
just glow in the dark and up like she
didn't know like when you get a fake
tooth you don't know
so i had to it's like
like the ultimate you have food in your
teeth and there was like a cute guy
there and i'd be like everyone was
talking about her i was like you have to
go home
everyone knows you have a fake tooth
right you can't if you have a fake tooth
you can't come to the night roller
skating party i love the idea of her
like
being looked at and noticing and just
looking at guys like
you know and it's just like where
i remember going hey one of your teeth
is like glowing in the dark she's like
what are you talking about later and i
was like do you think dude she's of
course not right like oh you outed her
about she's so she denied it it was just
me and her and i was like well
it's glowing in the dark right and no
one's gonna tell you what's crazy is
that all of them are fake except for the
one
[Laughter]
i don't have any fake teeth what are you
talking about get such a bummer i'm like
you need to get out of here so great
i'll call my mom she'll be here in an
hour
as a kid she goes to the pay phone and
there's like a collect
that's the reason operation smile like
work with that organization like to me
it's like always trying to figure out
like what do i do how do i help like
the idea of not being able to smile
without being embarrassed yeah as a
child before you even know that you're
poor or oppressed or like you're
that is the most fucked up thing to me
that as a child
when you try to experience joy by
smiling or greeting someone someone
laughs at you points to you or shames
you right you know what else it's just
traumatic that you have fucked up teeth
it's a it's
yeah sure uh i am a doctor
and psychiatrist before i get to my next
thing that probably made me uh try and
be funny i just want to say another
thing that's tough that and there's
nothing wrong with this being a white
man but like
can we get a break
crossed eyes
isn't that the toughest because yeah
we're such we're such visual like eye
contact people and if you have a crossed
eye are you born with cross ties well
you can get them if you just
i think i think you're bored
i think they put you down i had a homie
who had it and his mom had it so i it
might be hereditary okay but they put
you down
um i haven't seen someone with cross
eyes in a while someone today
where i'm not gonna say i was just
saying no but like and then like did you
make a quick trip to reno i i gotta stop
on the way here but yeah
thank you for supporting sex workers
[Laughter]
i of course like i'm like hey excuse me
can you help me find something and turns
around and like hits me with it and i'm
like right away i go this is fine it's
not a big deal right i'm an adult
i i just need to establish which i
right
because like they know that i'm they
know they know that i'm busy like for
the first 10 seconds of meeting that i'm
trying to figure out which one is this
pre or post math mandate because if
that's the only thing you see on a
person they were indoors so they had a
mask right like you're working um but i
always thought like god that's a fucking
that's that's tough because how many
cross-eyed actors have made it
as like like that's the last thing that
we need a rapist or pedophile or
murderer well there's like the one guy
who had crossed eyes from like um one
who flew of the cuckoo's nest that guy
he has crossed eyes but of course he
played like a crazy person yeah who's
the other person who's just by the way i
just googled famous cross-eyed people
uh ryan gosling came up first no and
andy cohen sorry i'm on infowars.com
should i go to a different website steve
buscemi actor steven shelby has a very
distinctive eyes no this is just a bit
like wonky eyes yes i'm talking about
like full on crosstalk i'm done with
google google is a hater yeah you're
going back to uh that was like someone
at google was like
let's make the search just like
cross-eyed people and they just put
people that like rejected them in high
school or something this feels like per
a personal a friend go
great sound cue the yeah well now we're
talking jingles are jingle sound cues
well no because remember like when in
the in the
like when budweiser did the
the adviser the
toads frogs was uh like different
commercials what was up was with those
senior frogs the big dudes and then bud
wise herb what's the frogs oh
but anyway but i think i know every
commercial jesus christ we get it you
auditioned for commercials when you
first got out you got your new teeth but
just cross-eyed famous people yeah but
not even famous like
actors that are in stuff like movie
stars like because i'm sure there's
well-known people with crossed eyes but
not people that we put in these
positions of like that person's uh a
cool us spy
what is happening
oh my god ryan gosling's his eyes go
outward
they're not on the same team right ryan
gosling's eyeballs one is chatty
chatting over here and the other one's
like hey we're busy they're not but i
would say that i'm now thinking of a
couple people whose eyes go out but in
cross okay so if your eyes like are
looking different places like on their
own journeys i think you can get away
from this side
outward because ryan gosling's eyes are
i think his or more different sizes so
they just look wonky
but he's also thought it was one of the
like hottest people on the planet that
was you did the roast that was one of my
favorite roasts of all time what was uh
somebody said a joke about bill hater
and they go bill you could do an
impression of anybody it's amazing you
can do an impression of anybody except
for a person with the same size eyes
really funny
that's really funny and so dumb so so
back to my fascination with you because
you're relentlessly funny in a way that
actually is like frustrating to me and
makes me jealous
but you seem to have to be very kind
caution is working comedy normally comes
from
pain or meanness here we go ready yeah
also
fucking the dumbest kid you've ever met
and still am you're dumb yeah
okay yeah i disagree no no no like full
on
uh i don't think you can be as quick as
you and be dumb well that that's been
i've trained that i mean you're like
dumb but you're not stupid you what does
that make sense no i say it you don't
say it i think um
everything we can be dumb so bad at
school like so yeah but a lot of really
smart people are about at school sure
but it's more mostly a memorization
exercise
i don't remember um
but you know what i'm saying it's like
we were like but but everybody who's
kind of smart like gets through school
fine i barely got out of high school but
school is about learning to comply and
learning like you're training don't do
that um
when you would go to a group study like
after school at night at somebody's
house like bring snacks we're all gonna
like
like grind before the exam or whatever
yeah
they didn't people would invite me and
i'd be like
this is gonna be fucking horrible and i
would go there and i would sit there and
i'd watch all these people who were
gonna go to these fabulous schools be
like right and then because that was and
that was actually her brother okay and
in 1854 or whatever like that country is
actually yugoslavia now whatever the
fuck it was yeah i would just sit there
going
more like migos lafayette
that's why you're invited and like but
like i just i was like such a dipshit
and didn't pay attention but on some
level you knew like this is all bullshit
like no i wasn't one of those kids
either who was like smarter than their
teachers and was like
savvy or whatever like
truly just because i was trained by my
dad to like question everything i think
also growing up like i went to catholic
school for a couple years and that's
when you are like
wait why can't you masturbate like like
i was the person like
when you grow up with those set of rules
that are just impossible to follow you
start having to ask some questions
i mean i definitely had like a sense of
self right where like i knew what i was
into i knew i had like at church there
was like a weirdo who uh we were all
saying
no we were all sitting around and he was
like we're all but you guys are all
becoming men you're getting older who's
got pubic hair and i was like
why are you asking us that
and he was like
yeah
you know
you guys are getting older but like i
had like that kind of sense of self but
like
that's interesting
i would question authority if it got
weird but i wouldn't question authority
and be like well
in the future we're gonna have
calculators and not have to learn math
right everyone like i wasn't that guy i
see but yeah that's interesting because
i was the
i was in an existential crisis my entire
kind of childhood and
which was like my dad's whole thing was
like
how do we know the maps are right right
i knew that i knew i know i know the kid
yeah i know who he is i don't know where
he is now but he was like smart but also
would be like you know what this book's
fucking bullshit fuck this and like
leave the class and i'd be like whoa the
holocaust didn't happen that well not
that but like i used stuff where i'm
like that's crazier than anything i've
ever done yet my dumb ass is in like
detention every day you know god and do
you think it's from growing up with
three older brothers like you had to
learn to be like entertaining and
charming and funny to not get beaten the
shit out of all the time no cause my
parents they're like who knew he was
gonna get into entertainment yeah be
acting because usually the youngest from
what i understand
a lot of people in the entertainment
business and a lot of really successful
people are the youngest because they had
parents were basically done parenting
right do you know if you were planned or
a mistake uh i think i was planned yeah
interesting i think i was planned i
think exactly they might have wanted me
to like be the girl yeah right right
yeah yeah yeah yeah ooh interesting you
think they were trying for like let's
try one more time to get a girl maybe i
don't know so having two older brothers
like you know
i that's that is just fascinating to me
because i i am my personalities i feel
like very defined by the fact that i am
the youngest and was not planned
youngest of
three basically it's a uh is it a step
brother
half i'm sorry half brother um and
what's a step brother it's when you're
if your dad was married before i had a
kid that you're you don't share any
parents right if your dad or mom married
a dad or mom who already had a kid you
guys are now step siblings god i'm
confused because i was i was working on
a joke about um i'm dating a guy that's
nine years younger than me and uh i was
working on a joke about um
i don't mean to be a hack and just bring
up jokes i'm working on but i want you
to know why i was confused about stepper
at that moment because that was a
a really ignorant dumb
like
like if i didn't know the difference of
that you guys should like check me into
an institution it was interesting
because you you do have a
half brother and you didn't know the
difference i got half brother and step
brother i i just realized like i
couldn't tell you the difference uh gun
in my head right but the reason i've
stepped brother i've been thinking about
a lot because uh i was trying to write a
joke about how people were like oh
younger guys they grew up on porn and
all this toxic fucked up porn and i was
trying to go for the angle of um
no one talks about the negative
ramifications of porn on men like the
guy that i'm with he has all these fears
that older guys don't have you know
because he's watched so much porn like
he won't let me alone with the pizza guy
you know right right he
whenever i visit my stepbrother he's
really he won't let me be alone with my
stepbrother
like i just
had a stepbrother in my head a lot it's
kind of sad how like
i mean maybe it's not who knows but like
kinks used to just be kind of like
physical and now they're like mental
where it's like isn't it naughty you're
fucking your stepmom and it's like i
don't is that great are we that out of
women that we're going to stepmom that's
like every category or maybe they're
just like throwing all the buzzwords in
the thing it's like blowjob fuck step
mom question mark i just all the
i just think
porn in general like when i go on there
and see all this stuff now i just i
almost find it more progressive than
hollywood at this point it's a lot of
moms are working that's right that's
very true all the women are homeowners
little people are all over it all over
the diversity in porn like they figured
out the inclusion rider and also the
women in porn they they're they they've
got a staff mm-hmm infection
they've got gardeners they've got pool
boys they've got plumbers they've got
handyman
they're lawyers they're doctors we just
need to get back to the classics you
know
face fucking you know it's called skull
fucking is it yes skull fucking is when
you fucking eye socket oh
right i thought that was a mouth slide
into whitney's dms and tell her if
that's what it is
i mean my eye sockets are uh
perfectly qualified to get fucked
because my ancestors got punched in the
face a lot i think skull fucking is one
of those like
why are you evolved to have deeper eyes
yes because my ancestors were skull
fucking there's like a sack like outline
divot or whatever i thought i didn't
realize skull fucking was in the eyeball
i think skull fucking is one of those
like imaginary sex things like
that
cleveland steamer yes but that's real
that's sadly so real right just people
should spitting on other people like the
one that's the dolphin felching wasn't
that like the or is felting real
whatever the one is that we've talked
about on our podcast yes
mung diving yes
which katya explained to me monk diving
is when you and your friend go through
obituaries find a recently dead hot
chick go to the graveyard and dig her up
lay next to the gravestone then you and
your friend flip a coin the loser has to
put his or her mouth on the dead girl's
vagina and the winner jumps from the top
of the gravestone on the dead chick's
stomach shooting dead juice into the
loser's mouth that's actually that's the
guts come out of the
coochie that's actually not what i
thought it was uh the way katy explained
it to me is that mung diving is you find
a corpse that's like five or six days
old and you get high on the fumes sure
of the toxins that are being emitted
from the corpse and you like can get
high off of it no it's the it's it's
i've heard that it's
body in the sun
it's it's like it gets distended
it gets bloated and then someone puts
their mouth what is this podcast
jumps on the stomach and then when the
intestines shoot out of the vagina they
go in your mouth and you come
[Laughter]
um
yeah so i think skull fucking is in like
that camp where it's like
yes it's not real yes it's not real okay
so back to your why you're this funny
because if you're if you haven't had
like some kind of singular trauma or
consistent trauma and you're this funny
it it fucks up my whole
like paradigm right you know what i mean
because you you where did you get all
this like kind you're like a kind person
with a big heart there's no shadiness
and i don't mean it as um that even when
people are mean or or nasty or have
character defects that always comes from
a place of pain too but like i've been
in this business for a long enough time
for comedy a long time that show
business showbiz the biz of show baby
and that you're just one of the very few
people
that i'm like
you dan levy uh dan levy also but stand
ups and comedy people there's some
people you're just like
no one has a bad word to say
there's no sketchy weird gross stories i
think um
but i you know what though you're not a
bully you're not toxic i give um the
worst first impressions usually i don't
disagree with that because
i'm serious i am too because
i think people are ready to joke
right off the bat i definitely think i
thought you were dick when i first met
you right and so i go like let's joke
and like zing and people go i we just
met and i go well and you're tall and
handsome and
that doesn't help either that i i look
like a bad guy from an 80s movie right i
actually wrote down
uh uh
that
you are
roles that i would give you a straight
offer for not me as a i'm i'm out of the
business i'm retired but i'm saying like
you're i'm fascinated by because in your
career watching the roles that you do as
we just got to do a movie together not
in the same we'll get to that place
we'll get to that in a second but you're
playing this like smug kind of famous
asshole in which is like it's such
perfect casting no offense but it made
me laugh so hard is this i love being
able to
describe someone's personality or
what they give off right right because i
feel like you're
you're kind of in the wrong body like
you're yeah i feel that way does that
make sense i feel like i've got a very
like larry davidness to me that like the
guys know because they're like why what
what's the hang up and i'm like
this and they're like you shouldn't have
that hang up and i'm like but i do and
they're like nobody cares because of how
i look or whatever like you
if i just saw you in the wild i'm like
oh that guy gets all that you fucking
douchebag and never heard knowing his
life like just captain of the football
team like that's
right this was captain god
um
so str i was just trying to i actually
do try to prepare for this podcast and i
have a little document for you of
questions i want to ask and things
things that would be a straight offer
for anders
massage guy the guy at work who wants to
give everyone a back massage
back massage guy you know that guy yeah
yeah yeah he was like ah who's just
giving him oh you're tense
wow you're tense
guy who mimes playing sports while
waiting in a line just oh i mean that's
my dad
that's my dad my dad was like my dad was
a football player and a golfer like
fascinating yeah he was like fucking
cool you know he was like
the um the fraternities from animal
house that they hated amazing yeah like
who would play him in a movie about his
life bradley cooper uh dennehy
bro uh brian dennehy oh yeah yes yes yes
brian danny is like my dad i got thrown
and i was like sudegas um uh my dad
always will just be like
working on his golf swing just kind of
like without a golf club yeah yeah
i love someone that works on their
sports just
in public yeah
because i also i i don't know where i
pitched this or where i tried to put
this i wanted to do maybe it was like an
snl packet 20 years ago or something the
the guy that mod
yeah
by the way
let me tell you something i never
submitted for snl right but i did write
a sketch that i want to tell you about
in a second because it still makes me
laugh it was so stupid um but
uh
i do need to find my mad tv audition
though because that was that is one for
the books
yeah it was embarrassing um
the guy that because i'm not like a
character person i don't like come up
with characters but yeah you're not a
character yeah
caricature people keep doing this i'm
just joan rivers yeah um so
the guy that mimes playing basketball or
whatever in line but
the guy that does it and then in his
imagination misses and he's like fuck
the idea that's just the rebound oh man
it's like you imagined it
why miss right right the idea that like
your dad's practicing his golf swing
it's like fuck yeah it's like you didn't
have to miss right visualize success in
victory don't visualize but maybe
they're like you know they're trying to
prepare themselves for failure too
because it's also the kind of person
that's practicing their swing obviously
wants to get better all the time and
it's probably self-flagellating so
there's something funny about someone
beating themselves up over an imaginary
swing that they didn't make
i like that that i was a lonely person
and this is the kind of so the the thing
that i was right for snl tell me if this
is funny is someone i can't believe i'm
pitching this to you uh is someone who's
um
uh tasting comedy i admire so much
didn't i tell you about this because
emily used to work at us now mm-hmm the
so you got hired there
that's an assistant she was lauren
but you were there i was on staff well
like would this have gotten in you
probably went to some auditions i bet
i've saw all the auditions
my favorite audition ever on snl and
i've seen all of them because they keep
a record were you allowed to laugh at
the auditions
tim robinson did an audition i was with
him last night i fucking loved the
funniest dude he did an audition of an
amazing actor who did like a um who
could act anything but couldn't sleep so
he was like did this monologue with
anybody like this and now it is time to
bed
oh like that's the one thing he couldn't
add
so he'd be like
i've had enough of this yeah i'm moving
out tomorrow you can't handle the truth
i'm gonna go to sleep
that's very funny oh fucking yeah but
that is
so genius like the one do you now want
to pitch yours after like yeah even more
even like even more so
i will die on this hill
because i do believe that actually
the the way that whatever skill i have
could be the best used
would have been being a writer on my
colleagues
like they're like i i that's my shit is
like workaholics like it's always sunny
and workaholics for the two shows where
i was like i don't know which is which
where i was like if i
didn't need my dad's approval so badly
like to become the stand-up comedian
i would be happiest writing on one of
those shows yeah um the sketch that i
wrote uh
for the packet i don't whatever was it
was about you know guys always have
nicknames for each other like chief
champ bunnies
bro durs whatever
and it's a bunch of skies what is it
hoss what's hoss it's just like what's
up hoss like for a big guy
chief i know it's a ma what's up chief
what's up chief chief that's i mean
boss man boss man boss man shit like
just helping you out
if you're if you're going to do this as
a stand-up routine at some point i'm not
throw hoss in there and it'll get some
dudes in the back and go
they'll just lose their mind she said
that's my hey honey that's what i say
right
she said i feel i don't i don't think
burke crusher's fans are gonna be uh
coming to my shows anytime soon
you never know
no we both take our shirts off at the
end of the
we're show a break
i love about taking a break from the
laughs i laughed harder at this show
than i've left it
really
yeah you called it out you were like
stop laughing oh i that was anders is so
funny yeah he kills me kills me um
everyone's again can you get back to
please
what are you doing because it's that
time where we're gonna stop and and joke
about how we're mentally ill
it's about that time where we pretend
like we take care of our mental health
speaking of inappropriate laughter
better health
i don't need it at all i eat grief for
breakfast
uh here's the thing
headaches
teeth grinding is wait is is this my
book
where's this oh this is the better help
copy sorry look
here's the thing here's what i've
learned in therapy i've learned that if
you need help ask for it grace take it
away it is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so
whitney like while she's in a podcast
sometimes if you see her on her phone
she's like tippity-tapping around on her
screen she is probably texting her
better help therapist being like this
guest is stressing me out i don't know
what to say next or just being like i
don't have any money left uh can i can
we please use my promo code this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp and good for
you listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com whitney that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash whitney i haven't i
haven't door dashed my breakfast this
morning and i have low blood sugar
and if you could get what you wanted to
eat right now to your door with doordash
you could order any type of dip any type
of juice those are whitney's main
by the way you said dave i went huh i
know you love that sometimes you just
need a dip okay i was i just wanted to
um look at my door dash orders the last
ones uh one was from a place called
juicy ladies that's a food place i swear
also my nickname uh that's what emily
calls her boots
that's what i call my hemorrhoids
some sushi yeah there's over three
hundred thousand partners on doordash so
you can get your local favorites like
juicy ladies whatever that is nuts look
at this or you can get like cheesecake
factory you can get national chains you
can get chipotle it's the only place you
can order chipotle i mean it's tricky
because i normally go to cheesecake
factory for the ambiance right but but
if you're like really in a pinch
ordering is easy and your items will be
left safely outside your door when you
choose contactless delivery drop-off
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app and enter
code gfy i order from goop chip nope
goop chicken i mean that's basically
goop kitchen oh good it's goop it's
going to pacho's goop chicken
kitchen
do they have having a string
do they have chicken
and i got one spring roll one egg and it
was 280 dollars and can they bring you a
vagina steamer but it could have been
cheaper because with code g for y you
can get 25 off up to a ten dollar value
ten dollars only paid
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code gfy don't
forget that's called gfy for 25 i've
never forgotten anything in my life
don't forget that's code gfy for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
to change term supply
i mostly use it to get my third coffee
back to anders okay so it was because i
guys have nicknames guys call each other
nicknames and it was like a scene where
a bunch of guys were watching football
together and i was like what's up dude
you know yo boss pass me the doritos yo
champion you know buddy give me that and
then someone's like yo durs go uh order
pizza and you're like cool you're at
your friend's apartment and then you
call the pizza place and
they're like
boss what do you want uh uh pepperoni
cool champ
and then the pizza place is like what's
your address gives the address like
what's the name on the buzzer
and you're like he doesn't know his
friend's name
just the idea that it's been so long
that you called your friend their first
name um it's all building to that one
moment of like
because there are people in my life who
they have nicknames or something where
sometimes i do have to be like what's
the oh like that's your name well you
the new the new school shit of that is
calling people by that you've never met
in person by their like ig handle
oh like i think adam devine has a story
of how
he kicked it with somebody for like
months
and it was always like chief haas a lot
of like boss man and
he one day the guy introduced you never
called woman boss adam two
yes you do
um
lady balls oh and leona is different
yeah she's about to have to be girl boss
girl girl no woman yeah about b a w s
uh so the guy goes
uh
this is andy andy bovine and adam's like
adam's like
yeah no that's what and he goes
what he's like
you just that's my instagram name he
goes i thought that was your real name
he goes no it's adam devine and he goes
why is your instagram name andy bovine
it's so close and different he goes
because that was a joke name from back
in the day
but it was like a moment of like a
record scratch
yeah so
your thing is
for real so i should submit to snl now
yeah
send them a facts question
uh question
this just reminded me someone the other
day
what was your first screen name like aim
screen name or email like your first
because our first emails were so dumb we
had no idea that this was going to be a
real thing we thought it was just me
flirting with silly man i didn't think
this would be
mine was cute mook at aol.com my dog was
named mookie growing up
and like
everyone's first aim name was like like
sweetie baby 62.
i think mine was nordictracks
with like an x
that's good
because i'm scandinavian
and like nordic track was like a thing
the fact that we put so little thought
into our screen names back then now our
emails are identity i mean it'd be
weirder if it was like
anything cool like right like yeah i
don't know mine was m
26 m-bop from like hanson that's
is that why you still have the haircut
from the handsome boys wow come on
come on do you see how long it took me
to like even firing on your podcast are
you guys looking for not you
just we're teaming up
by the way this is an example of me
having just met you again we met several
years ago when you came to oracle hawks
but uh of me dissing you to your face
and probably leaving a bad impression
everybody i know is like like guys who i
met in college were like we hated you
with the first week that's that's like
people say that with me and they're like
and we still hate you
but you how did you get over my fence i
also met i also think sometimes
i also
will say i was on an episode of
workaholics i
really feel like i bombed it and i
really i felt like
uh because i was a fan of you and i met
you in a situation where i was did you
hear me say that you bombed it well no i
read the email you guys shouldn't have
cc'd me on the editing notes like saying
like
but i remember going into a situation of
like
like and i i've been listening to your
your podcast um for some reason and um
walking into a situation where three or
four i mean in the whole crew are so
are
it's like it's like go going to a new
school when you're like 13 and coming in
halfway through the school year and
you're up there you watch the school on
comedy central already
right
i mean that's but everything you're like
walking into a situation where everybody
is so funny and so good together and
like i come from stand up where it's
like everyone is their own island right
and like
everyone just being so generous like is
improvised wasn't funny i remember
coming in and i remember like being in
between takes being like i am bombing
this they are so funny
i'm ruining this show
you were super funny you were super
uh
outgoing and like game like as as long
as people show up our game to like be a
buffoon because your character was
insane yeah uh
that's all we can ask for if someone
comes in who like we're stoked to have
on like we were stoked to have you and
then they're kind of just like buttoned
up yeah we're always like
like the reason we're having you on here
so that you can
go crazy and do something stupid yeah um
you know and we were lucky to have a
bunch of people who
did that because it's also such a
specific tone like you're walking into
like a very specific tone that's like i
don't want to feel like i'm like
just trying to do with you guys i'm like
you guys are like i'm one of you right
but you it's like this weird dynamic
where you kind of have to like go like
i'm just gonna
i just want to make these guys laugh and
if they like it that's all that really
matters but we met under those
circumstances and i remember being
intimidated by you that's not how we met
fuck
you don't remember this give it i don't
so this is when you talk
so this is how and i don't know if i can
we can cut it later no no we don't
please okay uh and i i retold you this
story at workaholics because you didn't
remember it
um
we went out to dinner when i had been in
la for
maybe a year and you'd been there for
maybe like six months
we went out to dinner with
jordan rubin
and
sean lennon who jordan grew up with
right
and
my wife my girlfriend now wife was there
too and i was like she had just moved
out here because she's younger than me
uh i was still finishing school she just
came out here and i was like hey we're
gonna go to dinner with this guy jordan
he's a stand-up super funny and i think
sean lennon is gonna be this dinner
and she was like what like why would
shawn lennon want to go to dinner with
you you fucking loser my boyfriend um
she keeps me grounded
and
we go to dinner and you're there and
you
you
are so much fun at this dinner and i'm
like so like i'm like
this person's gonna be so famous so fast
and
you
jordan was like we played a game the
other day
he was living with simon rex
do you know what it is
okay
i do know this okay so let me let me
just yeah a couple footnotes and we will
tell the story about this game
so
i you know when sometimes you ask
someone for directions and as soon as
they start telling you the directions
you zone out and start like looking at
their freckles and so so when i
at workaholics i was disassociating
because i was nervous like i do
specifically remember talking to you at
your off in your office in that like
dark hallway did you hear you the lock
when i hit the button under my desk
matlab the matt lauer button
so i remember specifically going i want
to meet this person i want to talk to
this person i'm a fan don't embarrass
yourself i already was in a little bit
of like i don't know i mean you are in
every movie that's been released in the
last uh seven years so
are you ever on a set and you're just
like
you get insecure and you're just like
yeah of course yeah i was just insecure
a thousand percent and i remember
talking to you and being like
looking down at myself going like pay
attention to what he's saying he's
trying to talk to you but that my brain
was like he's just trying to be nice
even though you're ruining his show
there was i will have i can have
conversations with people where i just
go offline
and because i was in fear like i was in
total fight or flight mode and like
scared i was ruining your show
um
so i don't remember you telling me the
story at work
full disclosure i don't remember you
retelling me this story yeah i'm still
an asshole fair no no yeah so we were at
a bar one night and there was a game
that was being played oh it was at a bar
it was at a bar it was called the well
yeah a place called the well yeah yeah
i'm in the well mm-hmm and i like
and digital cameras
were brand new it was a k
easy
right i mean it was a camera that was
like
had the screen on yeah but it was like
it wasn't connected to a phone it wasn't
connected to a phone and it was it was
there was an era where like
people would bring out digital cameras
as kind of like a flex to be like
i've got money and like
i do this and jordan was like a
filmmaker so he had like a nice game yes
he's always been like a photographer
type of guy yeah and it's a camera where
you could take a picture and then you
could see the photo right and he was
like it was me simon rex maybe like two
other random people like girls and
they're like let's play a game where
everybody goes in the bathroom take the
dirtiest picture you can craziest the
craziest picture
okay it was like take the craziest
picture you can think of don't and then
the next person does it but you're not
allowed to look at what the people
before you did and let's see who just in
a vacuum who took the craziest picture
right so
the funniest thing to me is that jordan
goes so here's my picture and it's
jordan with his doing a mangina he puts
his dick between his legs and shows like
a mangina right picture and then and
then he goes here's simon rex's it was
the exact same thing coincidentally and
then a girl one of the girls did a photo
of just her pee
going into the toilet right and then
what was your photo mine was
finger in the asshole
and
jordan was like
we were shocked
like
we kind of wish the game didn't happen
like it crossed the line but like
obviously made the story and my wife who
had just moved to hollywood
gets like jordan passes the camera
around you're like i don't care whatever
it's so stupid yeah sure and i look out
i go
and my wife's like can i see i go yeah
look and then we're like what is that
and then because it was like a weird
angle
and then it was hard to take a picture
of your finger in your own asshole it's
not it
so
the drive home was fascinating
my wife's like yeah i don't what are we
doing out here i'm gonna be famous
i have to be singing
i just got these new teeth yeah
well it was just like
and i remember being like oh
i'm not i'm
emily
i am so funny i
play to win i also remember i'm a pro
i'm an overachieving perfectionist i
remember just being like
in my brain it was just it was well
groomed it was all also the obvious
thing to do and i also like didn't even
think i was gonna win the game i
remember being like right you thought
the stakes were super hot i remember
like a thumb i mean between simon rex
and jordan like right i mean this is
i mean
i was so far off base
in terms of what i thought this game was
and i actually did an episode on the
sitcom i did for nbc about this very
thing because it made me realize how
intense
just off the grid i am in terms of
what's like acceptable and appropriate
now when you were taking this awkward
picture i was like you step out of your
body and look at yourself for not at
that moment that when you went to a
dinner and showed people a picture of
your thumb in finger finger in your
butthole and then you've forgotten that
you'd met and by the way
this is the craziest meeting of any like
i i could meet anybody
so it was like you know when someone is
like let's play a party game and you're
like oh here we go like
and i remember being in the bathroom
being like
like should i put right i was getting
like i got to go bigger guys this was
like i'm not going to win this but i
need to be fun i don't want them to
think i'm not fun i'm not participating
you know what i mean i remember being
like
like the fact i settled on that like i
feel like right right i feel like there
were crazier things that weren't photos
you like cut yourself and you're like i
can't show them that you got a bunch of
toilet paper look i can't pull the fetus
out from my okay i guess i'm just gonna
can i the the camera won't flash inside
my pussy so i guess it just looks like a
black like i feel like it was what i
settled on and i thought i was gonna get
like second place or third place
and then cause i remember coming out
being like
all right like what a stupid game like i
know i'm gonna lose this and then
because then the game was everybody at
the end looks at the photos together
right and it's hilarious it's like simon
rex mangina the p and then it gets to
mine and everyone was like
a bummer
it's
hilarious i did win though but and so
for from that my takeaway that night was
you just seemed like
settled in
around people you seem comfortable
around people that's interesting which
is something i was like how does she
fucking do that and maybe
uh after today maybe you're like you
go for broke
right so you go big or go home kind of
thing and it didn't occur to me i was
going big that's the other thing i think
that's when you're like occurred to me
that you were going big either i was
just like wow she's so comfortable like
around these people meanwhile i'm like
what the fuck are you wearing anders
this is fucking the coolest dinner
you've been to
united and i knew you were like a
stand-up and if uh if jordan vouched for
you you were like legit you know and i
was like interesting as you say this it
kind of breaks my heart you're kind of
because i was
i've i was i do look back at that time
and i don't know if it was just
stupidity or naivete or i look back at
that person and that i'm like i was so
confident about that and i look at
myself now and i'm like
like the that the confidence that got me
whatever i got then getting it and being
dragged through over the coals publicly
and
like i'm now insecure and not that
person right yeah i'm not i i cannot
believe the amount
to be fair that person took a picture of
her finger in her butt
with everybody don't need to humble her
we need to scale it we need to scale it
back she can go away yeah we need to
scale back but so so let me ask you
about your wife i'm obsessed with you uh
you you and your wife met when you were
16 years old yeah high school high
school and then uh you've talked about
how when you went to college but you
stayed together like
this is something that is
i think a part of the reason for the
longest time i was like i don't even
know how to attune to him because that
yeah it's uh i was like is this an amish
is this a mormon thing like just i have
no data that a man would just love a
woman for that long and want to be
monogamous even when they got famous so
she's super dope of course how small is
her pussy jesus christ um
he's not gonna get in it i don't think
i'm just saying i think i'm not gonna
get into her pussy
that's how it is right
i'm just saying like that is something
that
i've hinged like most of the managing my
sort of disappointment or insecurity
about not being an imminent or not
having found a relationship is like
because guys just don't do that i have
all these bullshit stories in my head
and you debunked that well like i mean
we did take time off uh like in college
and in high school we were like on and
off and stuff so like other people have
been in our lives or whatever
but like
then moving out here
the place i grew up is kind of unique in
certain ways where it's just like this
socioeconomic
like science experiment where you're
exposed to a lot of different people and
like then you go to like college in
wisconsin and you're like where are the
black people and everyone goes
it's part of like how i grew up
um and then you
get out to la and you're like you look
how i look and everyone assumes a lot of
stuff about you and yeah
but then so if you have somebody who
grew up where you grew up in this place
that's you know it's not like super
unique but it's just different and where
you go evanston illinois outside chicago
and um
she we have a shorthand about like
values and things we want and like uh
acceptable
behavior as far as like you know just uh
yeah so it's just she's dope she's cool
but it's also the most the people that i
admire the most and there's that flue
bear quote that i uh
always screw up um but uh be
who quote um flo bearer am i pronouncing
it right is that like a vacuum company
be regular and orderly in your life so
that you may be violent and original in
your work will ferrell steve carell like
a lot of the great all have that
tattooed on there
yeah um no they have stable
relationships with people they've been
with for a very long time right so it's
like you're not going home to chaos so
in your professional life you can take
risks and and manage chaos because
you're going home to a safe consistent
place and i see so many many talented
people destroy their careers and lives
because they're constantly looking for
the upgrade relationship-wise or they're
just like
can't
accept
that a great thing already came along or
they're just wired to need validation by
yeah just smashing a lot of strange and
it's like kind of a weird word
it's kind of a weird
like genius uh get part of
like the gift of being able to be as
prolific as you yeah but like at the
same time like it's crazy at my house
you know i mean for different reasons
like every relationship right right um
and like
when you have a relationship that's like
this long like you and by the way like
to come out to la and like be like
okay like you're going to make it in
hollywood
you don't know like where to put a comma
and you're going to become a writer
she's like a journalism major and she
like taught me how to spell because i
just wrote i started writing movies
on based on watching movies right
uh
and like buying how to write screenplay
books and reading it myself save the cat
and stuff yeah i didn't know how to like
i didn't i'm not i can't read really um
so i don't know how to write that way i
had to teach myself another way but so
she's just kind of like trusting me and
was like
all right like i
she saw something in me that i saw
myself and so like when
it works you're like okay like
i want to make sure that she's got
everything she wants
here in la like
uh she works at a nonprofit which you'd
be surprised isn't like the most booming
thing in l.a right right usually like dc
or new york is where you you should go
and right um so to come out here and
like
and like i'm like a non-profit you mean
she's a comedian
right
that is not like where the pants for
like years you know what i mean where
she's like you need to cancel your
subscription to swimming world magazine
and i'm like but
i need to know what's going on before
the olympics um
like that kind of stuff where she's like
you can't get a blackberry because
you're poor you know what i mean like
the fruit not one yes i like i i start
myself
um but like
those kind of things where she kept me
in check and kept me focused and um
that's also super helpful and she knows
who i am before all this so like
even when like i get a big head about
whatever she's like
you needed me to do do i need to remind
you about your teeth yeah
she's like i used to lick them teeth
before they were fake how are your
children's teeth
oh they're all fucked up
but they're like they have like new old
like baby grown-ups they're only eight
four and zero i feel like the stuff
available to fix teeth now are so we had
like head gear you know like two rounds
of braces now
there's like very young kid braces that
you get for like six months to kind of
like set the table from six months old
no no no like uh
four four six months
as a young exactly and then like in high
school when they're really trying to
start to settle
then like you do it again for just a
little bit they realize like
like at 15 to just put half a basketball
hoop on someone's mouth yeah in like a
bunch of rubber bands and like a police
cottage the rubber band game was crazy
dude that was
wild the fact that there was just like
neon rubber bands in your cool colors
look you guys it's the screen
it says imagine kids running around now
with like it's the uh
dude head gear one false move and you
could just slash your own throat right i
did have a friend who got locked up with
his girlfriend like braced a branch all
the time yeah and the mom had to be like
you're kidding me right and like
get them apart how about this i was the
bitch who was like i want clear braces
because i don't want to see that i
braces
clear braces are like clear bra straps
like they're like invisalign no
you could get clear braces when this was
in virginia when i lived in roanoke and
my grandfather paid for me to have
braces and you could get clear the
little squares that were stuck to your
teeth it took
two years longer to have clear ones
right i said absolutely i got that kind
of time as long as they're clear
and they weren't clear they were
whatever color the food you just ate was
like you know what i'm saying they were
yellow they were right yeah it was just
disgusting right and uh yeah your
grandma paid for him my grandfather
grandfather yeah why don't you just make
him transition well i thought you said
grandmother and i was excited because i
was like oh both of our grandmas paid
for our teeth oh interesting my
grandfather paid for mine yes that's not
that interesting yeah like
that's not as good yeah uh i think if
we've learned anything from my
conversation with anders today it's that
we are best friends oh
i wish you were my best friend no you
only have best fiends i know i'm sorry
but the good thing about my best friend
best fiends is that once you download it
you can play it anywhere even without an
internet what did you do on your 22-hour
voyage to this wedding this year i went
to a wedding in aruba you know what i
did for 21 hours complained yep
and then for the other hour i played
best fiends and it flew by because i
didn't have wi-fi on the plane i can't
afford wi-fi on a plane
okay what airline did you fly i flew
united oh okay well yeah they can't
either yeah and i didn't if you could
yeah and i forgot your credit cards yeah
yeah yeah i did put my room on your car
it is
it is by the way more points for me
uh i get in that lounge i walk into that
lounge and they're like ma'am i'm like
the way i'm treated in the american
express lounge makes me think everyone
you're training so well you don't even
get on the plane
sometimes by the way we did okay best
fiends is an amazing game that we love
but we did miss our flight playing well
best fiends really helped me out because
i ended up being stuck in lax for say it
with me seven hours
and you know what i did i collected tons
of fiends and i got powered up and i
played even more levels than i had
before it was magical everyone came out
it was wild
that was like a month and a half ago
they're growing really okay will smith
it was a joke i am on level 300 and i am
just getting better and better you can
download best fiends for free from the
app store or google play plus even or
even more with five dollars of in-game
rewards when you reach level five
in scientology that's the one where you
get to learn about the aliens that's
friends without the r best fiends
now where can you go see some of your
best friends oh if you want more of this
coherent
cogent
quick witted
magical look i think everyone can agree
that now is the best time to be a
comedian
people love jokes
they love what we have to say
everyone has a sense of humor about
themselves
i just feel like
being a facetious roast type comedian is
just like really in demand right now
yeah so i'm going to be in houston texas
this weekend um just at a time where
people are just uh
assaulting um comedians let's go why
don't i go to texas where everyone can
have a gun at all times and also if you
can get slapped on national television
on a national network imagine what can
happen at the 713 music hall in houston
where i mean
let's do this
honestly i
just watched the just watch this new
piercing um
i'm going to be in texas this weekend
new orleans you guys know how to fight
april 9th i'll be at the orpheum theater
come at me bro
april 13th and 14th i'm gonna be in la
jolla lagola california at the comedy
store i always run my uh hour before i
shoot my specials in la jolla um so by
night that's a wednesday and thursday
i'm gonna be doing my specials and by
day i'm going to be um
verbally harassing all the stores that
still have ivory in their windows uh in
la jolla oh my god uh where are you on
april 22nd uh i've
the funeral probably uh but if i'm not
there i'm to be in portland oregon at
the arlene schnitzer concert hall who's
arlene is she dead too
um i don't i feel like most people that
have concert halls are dead um may 20
it's like you just name i is that the
tax workaround that if you die you just
buy a theater oh maybe a good idea i
think that's what this is
there's a lot of random theaters named
after people yeah joanne that why does
it go in yeah
yeah she's the most memorable one yeah
yeah
um tyson even may 20th tyson's corner
okay if you guys don't know look at roll
the footage of tyson's corner
24 years ago you will see me making bad
choices in the parking lot and emily
um
in an eyelet dress at build-a-bear
but
telling everyone that the bears are have
been appropriated uh and then
i have hannah emilian's head on her hand
at an indian wedding this is on may 20th
tyson's corner capital one hall um and
then i'm yeah we're doing that and then
uh june 26th i'm gonna be in toronto um
again well vancouver also
vancouver's happening that's earlier but
then i'm gonna be in toronto um and then
hey canadians i love you guys can't wait
but the hugging it's a wrap on that
after the pandemic and everyone getting
cancelled for hugging a little too long
my hands are so sticky from all the
maple syrup we're gonna be doing pounds
we're gonna be pounding it out okay
good for you is doing a live show
if you thought the oscars was a
mind-bending thrill ride
okay and we don't have somebody who's
bleeping
cutting to commercials right by the way
you i mean there we've got more we will
cover our physical violence with more
angles you will see it look careers will
be destroyed
brain cells will be um deleted
uh we are playing strip truth or dare
okay uh i've got a the kind of dares the
kind of dares i'm going with are like
i'm so scared
pierce your own ear with this um paper
clip oh see i'm excited for the truths
oh really oh i know i have written what
do you not know about me at this point
it's not what i don't know about you
it's what everybody else doesn't know
oh that is the angle from which i'm
approaching
don't give me like give me a for example
like i would do i this is the type of
dares i think we should do first of all
we're also going to do drugs
which believe it or not i'm not doing
right now i uh uh do like i want to do
like either
kiss my nipple or smack me in the face
i know what i'm going to do that's an
easy one
that's not really that's like
both of those are a bonus for us
on april 17th at 6 00 pm pacific
standard time
here we have to like really but we ought
to all get together with the burke
crusher truth and bears because he has
revealed so much and he's always he's
like i dare you to put his shirt on all
the time
uh we're gonna do questions and answers
are you guys gonna send us questions um
and i don't know you guys should pick
them because i i'm always i get stumped
how'd you get into comedy
i've answered that 500 times on the
internet like i'm not we we have to
don't be a dork with your questions
go to momenthouse.com good for you and
get your tickets it's a one time only
live digital event it's gonna be great
back to unders so let me ask you okay so
swimming so the fact let's go into it
the fact that you were a professional
swimmer is so
is that a professional i swam in college
you swam in college
but but there is a can i just
there's like four professional swimmers
and michael phelps is three of them
um you know i mean like it ain't really
cracking no
so there's no there's no career in
swimming like no there's there's about
like the marines they just started like
they just started a professional
swimming league i'm the only person that
watches it it's so sick though there's
like lights and shit it's like looks
like what's the website what's the isl
the international swimming league that's
so funny you should hook up with the
california condors they train out here
i'm not joking it's real but i'm you
know the gigi gorgeous was a
yes you told me this yeah because as
someone that played played basketball in
a couple like sketchy leagues like
pre-olympic leagues in europe and stuff
like that it's sort of like aau i did
like aau basketball there's all these
other sort of ways to do it that aren't
high school but
having the background of of sports and
athletes like understanding what it
takes to be good right i also think that
the people i know
i'm just gonna this is totally fake news
but i will defend it and die on this
hill the people i know that are in
the best healthy long-term relationships
played sports
because they're you know like
what you put in you're gonna get back
like you learn it's not just because
they're like their bodies are still in
shape
they're like well shit
she's still got it every girl i know
that was a professional gymnast is in a
happy relationship i can't they can do
this
i can't figure out why around their
house every girl i know that was a
famous ballerina has a husband i can't
figure out why no but i just mean the
mentality of like sports like it's this
you're constantly humbled you're you
realize you can't stay clean on the
shower you took yesterday like
you know
that okay that's an aaa slogan
why are you with yes and you're one of
the greatest improvisers on the planet
why can't you just like go with me on
this
i don't know if i fully agree with what
you're saying
like because for for comedy all yes and
we
yeah no i i i get i guess i get what
you're saying the skills like the work
ethic of being an athlete well i will
say that if you're a team sport player
it makes sense because you know how to
like jive with somebody and like yeah
football players are known for being
monogamous um
that's less of a team that's that is a
team sport but that's more of like a
um
not ever it's les you're less sharing
the ball in football right interesting
yeah the quarterback's got the ball the
running back gets it the receivers get
it based on this logic
team sports athletes would be good at
polygamy i'm talking about like soccer
i'm talking about like basketball we're
like you literal every player literally
can get the ball and be part of it right
yes so you work with people improvisers
maybe i don't know people who like
they know it's not all about them but
like swimming's a little different it's
a
it's a
singular sport for the most part because
it's just you right yeah but like my
wife played soccer she's a runner i
don't know i don't know about the
workouts there's definitely no
i'm just as i as i just moved to the
world i'm always trying to find things
to explain behaviors and personalities
like i'm like birth order
like birth order i'll i'll talk about
forever forever like but i'm kind of
when i go like oh the people in my life
that play sports are more like this or
the people in my life that you know
they're coachable
coachable teachers
willing to receive feedback
or
need feedback
right so like in a relationship there
will be a coach and there will be a
player interesting
and i'm the coach in my relationship
well or the ability to go you're giving
me feedback and it's not a criticism you
truly want me to be better not taking
feedback always as a criticism or
something or like personal yes or being
able to receive it and be like
i can i can see through the way you're
saying something
and separate how you're saying something
with what you're saying and i know that
if you're giving me feedback at all it
means you care on some level you know
what i mean it's like my whole thing in
relationships like if i'm fighting with
you i'm fighting for you also
and i'll say this out of like my
relationship
for my wife
she doesn't need me she needs running
right like i don't calm her down
she's like
miserable i'm gonna go for a run and she
comes back 45 minutes later and she's
like hey how are you going to get lunch
together so like i might even argue that
people who have this
uh
athletes or whatever
they have another way to find endorphins
and
to like clear their head other than like
in within people getting your emotional
equilibrium like you know how to they
can go reset on their own some people
will drink or jerk off or do it like
that's a healthy addiction some people
might go running
get a little horny go home jerk off and
have a drink yeah
but like she knows what she needs to get
her internal equilibrium which is i
think
if you're an athlete you understand your
body you understand how to you know
maybe it's just more that right i'm
reaching so this is fascinating to me
because when i meet someone that's been
in a relationship this long i'm like as
someone that saw four divorces by the
time i was 15 was very much like
inculcated with like half of marriages
educated it was instilled in me
things like um you know the uh monogamy
was invented when the life expectancy
was 40. monogamy's not natural like i
grew up around lots of divorces and a
lot of
cheating and a lot of people that needed
to
say um monogamy's a capitalist
conspiracy
uh uh the the the what is it the wedding
machine
of the wedding business
exactly so
i have fears about being in a long-term
committed relationship because number
one my biggest fear in life is
being boring being boring that's my
nightmare is to be sitting next to
someone and just like have nothing to
say yeah yeah yeah and like be bombing
yeah
um but i guess true love you can just be
silent and not i love that you think
it's true love it's not like it's not
like
i walk in the door and she's like here's
your fucking whatever sir like we kiss
and then we look at each other each
other's eyes and like
a healthy relationship yeah i mean it's
it's
but never run out of things to talk
about
no because life is happening right and
you're like you're you have kids and
then like you move or like new jobs
logistics
no it's uh i mean you could call
logistics if you're like a sociopath but
like i'm talking about interacting with
people cause those feel like texts this
feels like email yeah i mean we
definitely have those times where it's
like i'm living in a different world
than she is right and like i
was just in mobile alabama for two
months with sebastian maniscalco making
a movie and
it sucked and she was pregnant and like
she was in a world of like my family and
i was in the world making a movie with
like robert de niro and going out to
dinner and hanging out with the cast and
like
yeah um it's for sure not my kid
uh it's got one nipple just like adam
divine very strange
um but not nipple dimple so yeah you do
have those moments where it's like
you gotta get back on the same page
because otherwise like what are you
doing yeah right and then we just did
that um
i got back and said no to a humongous
project
so that you could father your children
yeah and she and now i'm like trying to
find the next thing if it happens yeah
and uh she feels bad but she shouldn't
feel because it shoots in a crazy place
uh just new york but it's just like a
long commitment um and she feels bad but
she shouldn't feel bad because it was
like a decision we made not something
that i felt like pressured by her
because it also wasn't perfect but um
you just gotta like cats too
it was cats too all buttholes
um
they might need your fingers i'm just
saying my audition tape's ready
um
yeah so like you just gotta like
i don't know i don't it's it's weird to
hear people talk about it in such
because to you it's so it's so second
nature it's not only second nature but
it's not magical it's not is it inhere
are your brothers in
line no
my brother's my oldest brother's single
my who's
uh what 46 or something like that and
then my other brother just got engaged
um uh
so we
so you work more than anyone i know
like you yes like i am so happy keep
saying that because i'm like i'm just so
trying to be free though
oh really
it's everything i mean so we just did
this i i mean i because when you have
like workaholics which is such a sure
thing every year you're like cool maybe
i'll do a movie like between
like it's crazy it was amazing um but i
with these guys you know and the fact
yeah and then now the podcast this is
important as you guys and i was
listening um to some episodes and it is
just like everything you would want from
a podcast like as someone that i go to
podcast for news sometimes because i'm
trying to not be like a complete waste
of space and moron and like know what's
going on in the world and it feels like
homework but like yours is like just
hanging out with your funniest friends
and it's
it's like i haven't really had a family
dynamic but i assume that's what it's
like to have a family you're just
hanging out with people that can it's
it's a very warm fuzzy
thing that i feel like tv now a lot of
tv wants to like lecture people on how
to vote and how to behave and tell them
how like sexist and homophobic and
racist they are
whereas a lot of people in america are
like that's just you guys we're kind of
just trying to watch tv to like laugh
and not feel like shit like we
work three jobs and kind of just like
it's it's i like where tv is going
he's gonna leave you on that island yeah
it's just like it's just like just like
hollywood lecturing
people that just kind of want to laugh
after their four jobs right right right
like it's just so fun you will learn
absolutely nothing no uh we talk about
news from like seven months ago like
after it's been like buried and done by
every podcast of the week
but you know what is crazy like no i you
know what i wanted to do on this this my
guys i wanted to do a uh segment called
like can we circle back
on something that happened before i had
a podcast that i i still need to talk
about um gwyneth paltrow and brad pitt
like i never got to
give you my take on it when it was
happening right like i still need to
talk about like in sino-man i'd like to
do a movie review i'll talk about that
because i do want to ask about all the
comedies and stuff that formed you um so
you were saying
before i started talking about this and
how how i have like you're saying this
as if it's it's some people listen you
can't see that no some people listen
okay so
but you were saying this is important
all the time and i was saying ah it
doesn't feel like that because i had
such a steady gig and now it's like i
feel like i knew that i am in demand as
an actress because i just got to do a
movie and then you texted me you're like
i'm in it and i was like oh my god i'm
in i'm in a movie that's going to come
out yeah
because all the movies i do either are
in development forever or they just come
out on like see so
so it was very exciting fun we got to do
we thought we were going to be in a
movie together
it was a bummer
we were in the movie but not together we
didn't get to be in scenes we had a
scene together
but they turned it into a phone call and
so we got to do this movie together we
can't really talk much about it but
we'll talk about it when it comes out i
mean we can but it's just not out yet
yeah
i got to see your they showed me your
footage oh good that's good yeah and
then uh i got to like act with your
footage right because i did improvise
stuff but then i was like how's this
gonna work like
and then good that they showed you
because then you could riff with my
ghost what movies did you watch growing
up can i guess what formed you
yeah well you were
illinois so you probably watch roseanne
yeah
that's you so lisa goranson yes was my
neighbor growing up crazy like she's
best crazy she was really good friends
with my brother ollie uh and i saw her a
couple years ago like that emmy's night
before party and she was like from
roseanne what the fuck yes the first
backyard yes the first becky and then
the now becky
yeah yeah which by the way i'm so fast
ep and work on roseanne so but i've
talked about this but not on the the
fact that there's an animal is that who
you're his animal what's that mean it's
short like roseanne like zan yours
animal anybody's a fan of roseanne's
animal
slide in her demon dms and tell her
you're his animal
don't do that please just keep sending
dick pics per usual
but what do you because i'm obsessed did
workaholics have names of fans
no because you know how like people have
like
you mean like we'd maybe yeah
beehive
no taylor swift or swifties like
workaholic yeah the liquors
i don't think so
um the workman yeah i'm just curious
like
because people
whatever
yeah if you're a big fan of workholes
i'm always curious because a bunch of
people have been like what would fans of
this podcast be called am i i don't
i thought that's what you were doing
what else did you watch were you wait
because i was a three amigos
uh national lampoon's european vacation
boobies i yep yeah he's gonna porker us
and i had like four or five movies that
my brother who was 10 years older than
me never returned to blockbuster and i
just watched them over and over again
coneheads with dan aykroyd blues
brothers with dan aykroyd originated on
snl i had old snl tapes of chevy chase
and dan aykroyd landshark was like the
biggest joke in my house growing up yeah
so i because i had an older brother i
kind of like
saw older comedies you know what i'm
saying yeah because you have older
brothers yeah um
so
any more guesses before i go into it um
true beverly hills
no
um and and what's the body shack
a million times of course yeah yeah yeah
um but like i liked roseanne and we
watched it because elise was on it like
we were like like we got and it was very
strange and is that what it felt like
because i remember watching roseanne and
part of the reason i obviously wanted to
do the reboot and it was i that was the
first show i watched that i was like
that's what my house looks like right
and that's how my family talks adam
devine talks about how that's what his
family was like he was like this is my
family like straight up my family was
more
i don't know we were kind of like
um
the poor people at the country club if
that makes sense yeah that was that's a
little yeah where i we we had like we
drove used cars
we didn't valet we would like park and
then like walk up with the valet guys
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh but belong to a
country club until i was like nine or so
like the check probably bounced yeah
it's like yes my parents would yell at
me when they're like you bought seven
frozen stickers exactly exactly we were
like that too it was like trying to keep
up with the joneses but not able to yeah
and then we
didn't go back to the club because uh it
got super expensive um
and then yeah so i watched i watched so
much television as a kid like
latchkey kid tv
constantly
uh i watched things very young um
i saw like animal house yep i'd seen him
probably like 20 times by the time i was
probably not eight years old this is
like perfectly designed for tick tock
remember when jim belushi had the egg in
his mouth and he
slammed it i talk about like labyrinth
all the time because it was like such a
big deal for me and a lot of people you
remind me of the babe the baby the power
the board
you do do what you remind me of the
faith
crying i don't think i didn't see that
on your computer
could i do i was playing that for the
other day for my kids they love it by
the way i i just played it for of my
friend dan levy's kids and they lost
their minds yeah they've never seen it
jim henson for kids yeah it is a bummer
that i mean david bowie is wearing no
panties in that and he is he's got a
piece on it
yeah yeah and but a lot of people that
are that listen to podcasts that are
really young
are watching labyrinths for the first
time and they're like what the fuck is
this nightmare yeah no it's you gotta
watch it
before you're like 14 years old
otherwise you're like this is weird i
guess because they're like you realize
jennifer connolly was 15 and he was 40.
i'm like okay
yeah it was different back then that's
just how you got dinner also he's evil
so it's okay he steals babies i don't
know and then i was like is that you eat
babies cute like q anon people lose
their minds when i say that's my
favorite the thing babies taste so good
they're i mean honestly
delicious i mean like a uh baby ranch
where we're growing babies
love robocop okay it's hyper violent
yeah and i saw it when i was probably
eight years old sure
um
what else labyrinth dark crystal whoa
big okay spaceballs never ending story
not a huge space pulse animaniacs no i'm
uh people my age watched animaniacs but
i'm a little older than that like yeah
i'm ducktales
i'm darkwing duck what were like your
comedy when you were like i want to do
comedy and you're like
watching things was it like
uh uh
you know ghostbusters whoa
big ghostbusters
and
like mr show like i like i just feel
like everyone's got their thing
chappelle show has their thing that mine
was like martin roseanne
for whatever reason mad about you like
that was my first like okay stand-up
comedians with shows huge i love cheers
i remember watching i remember watching
the cheers finale like when i'm supposed
to be doing homework and i was like
standing in our like tv room with the
collector like ready to turn it off and
like run out the door
cheers pilot perfect it's perfect it's
amazing and um
la soul their first couple albums with
like the sketches and the skits in there
interesting i fucking was like this is
the funniest thing i've ever heard in my
life that's fascinating um like three
feet high and rising de la soul's dead
those two albums are like
i'll just quote those we would just
quote those constantly that's
interesting like prince paul i mean i
don't know if you've listened to those
albums they're
almost impossible to find now because
def jam like sits on the rights and
they're not streaming anywhere
anyway um stand by me is like the
greatest movie of all time
stand by me with jerry o'connell
yes
okay
that mine the four kid the four kids
mine was like lord of the flies my
stance
huge i used to rent that huge way too
much it was real it felt very real to me
as a kid that was like my education of
like human nature right like that's the
only reason i've survived hollywood have
you seen yellow jackets on showtime no
it's the female or the flies okay it's
incredible yeah stand by me interesting
have you
remember my girl have you ever seen
um stand by me
i no
honestly
and i you guys can
chime in they're paid to agree with you
so you should watch it it's fucking
amazing i'm so sh i'm just really
surprised you haven't seen it i didn't
watch a lot of these like emotional
comedy i don't think children's stories
are interesting this is interesting but
i'm saying as a when i was a kid i had
to be so precocious and so adult i was
like dating older guys and i had to like
get myself home from school i was not
interested in stories about kids lives
this is river phoenix
oh wow yeah this is key for sutherland
uh with like guns i see guns and crying
you gotta see this movie okay i will
it's so fucking good it's it's based on
a stephen king book amazing it's uh
directed by rob reiner when he was like
on his fucking tear i remember watching
dead poets society a lot when i was a
kid yeah that was a little too
i have the emotions for me but like ace
ventura austin powers
um no like
you lose your mind watching these insane
characters right now there's this
movement in comedy where we need to like
use our platform responsibly sure fine
great but a comedy still needs to be a
comedy a stand-up special should not be
a lecture or a ted talk i don't i don't
want people as dumb as me that might be
funny telling me like about the world
like i'm a fucking idiot
no one should listen to me about almost
anything but i will act like a fool for
you yeah exactly that's that is
literally i'm a clown
sometimes i think stand-up comedian
sometimes like oh incisive commentary or
like whatever fine but i'm just i'm just
i get very excited when i get to talk to
a comedian who actually just like wants
doesn't want to run for office and by
the way um i understand that like to
have a platform is a privilege
and like it it is an opening to
to
inform people about something
but at the same time i'm not that guy
yeah if george clooney wants to do it
great he seems pretty smart
um do you really want your like
politicians doing comedy
no either like
it's comedy's like the only job where
they also expect you to be like a
scientist and a politician and a charity
worker or whatever like
what's the most annoying thing um yeah
what's the most annoying thing about
flying southwest it's like the the the
flight attendants like want to do comedy
and you're like oh like it's like
yet we put all this pressure on
ourselves to be able to do everything
else although i did
was thinking about i wrote this down i
found this in my notes app the other day
pitching a stand-up special for just
southwest airlines
flight attendants
because some of them had some something
i'm sure i don't know why it's just that
airline though because think about how
many flights they're doing a day like
they're honing that material it is the
captive audience and i just saw the worm
over there no i'm just wearing oh i'm
just warm yeah yeah wait and then you
said did i watch my girl my girl yeah
segway um yeah of course i watched my
girl it's amazing and i just worked with
anna klumsky of my girl fame thanks and
inventing anna which i was just bringing
up right right how weird is that and i
play i played uh
it was amazing i played my girl for my
kids
and they loved it
is that child abuse
old yeller my girl i feel like they
loved when he gets killed by the bees
yes
people die you you know that right uh
they watched it they loved it i think
disney movies are insane the fact that
like they just like bambi to me is the
most traumatic thing that happened yeah
but like you gotta these are i was
molested as a kid and i'm like bambi was
traumatic yeah uh by a deer a deer a
deer a dear friend of the family rod
it was on ice
um but yeah i i showed it four of them
and the big takeaway was
when dan ackroyd your favorite
and jamie curtis are out playing bingo
in this like small town
the kids follow them because they're
like oh my god they're on a date and
they don't want them like to hook up and
they're about to kiss and the kids she
jumps out and goes bingo and like they
don't kiss because they think whatever
so now my kids whenever me and my wife
are like gonna kiss around the house
they shout bingo
and it's like the fucking best they're
like bingo but remember she
worked in a funeral home am i making
that up like a funeral yeah
yeah they lived there they lived there
and she was like a hypochondriac she
always not hyper contract but she always
thought like she was had some kind of
ailment well bitches be crazy
it must be surreal like when you
you've read my diary
when
it must be surreal as like whenever i
work with someone that was like one of
my heroes as a kid it does it ever stop
being a little weird um
no
it's always good good always weird right
it should be um every time polly shore
calls me even when i'm annoyed i'm like
it is weird that i'm like sending
polly's short a voicemail right
and you're wheezing the juice that's a
beautiful thing
um
no paulie did workaholics and he was
fucking he's hilarious awesome he's
hilarious he was so good we were like so
the bit is that like you're up for
auction will you get in this cage and he
was like
yeah yeah man
yes i will it was great uh
but anyway so yeah it never gets old and
i told this story somewhere the other
day so i hope i'm not doubling up but
i
was an announcer at the nhl awards a few
years ago and i'm backstage
and i'm just waiting around like for my
category or whatever best coach or some
shit and
somebody comes up to me and they're like
hey sorry to bother you um
i'm the announcer over the loudspeakers
like you've been listening to me all
night blah blah
my daughter's a huge fan of yours can we
get a picture before you leave for the
other night and i go
absolutely
wayne gretzky oh
no because he was the announcer of the
night oh sorry wayne gretzky's
not doing that but oh sorry i look at
him and i go
you're roger rose you're the star of ski
patrol
and he was like
yeah i go dude i've seen ski patrol 1000
times
and i was like he's like oh that's so
nice to hear i go dude i'm
me because of you like your dna of like
putting stuff out there like your
daughter
loves you
through me you know what i mean like
that like
that's the craziest thing about this
business is that
these people you've grown up watching
seeing maybe even like forgetting about
but like
they're in your hippocampus i might have
watched that movie 20 times over a
winter break and then not again for a
decade in their fabric of like the
the moments that
got you through
like your life right
they've incantationed what was the word
you used they've been stupid they've
inculcated
um
your comedy or your sensibility there
might be a word from a movie that you
say a certain way
because of that and that's it and like i
mean that's things like elena's morris i
was going to come on the podcast and we
had to reschedule for a couple reasons
i'm like i don't even think like i don't
think you
like you understand
me how to
you taught me this like spectrum of
emotions like you it's it's you're
programmed to be the specter emotions is
the four different versions of her in
the car during your life you're like
there's straight hair braids
there's
like you'd sweater over the sleeves
yeah you taught me that
if you go to a movie with a guy you're
supposed to blow him in the theater
how else would i have known that yeah i
would have just sat there and watched
the movie like an asshole right
so okay inventing anna we are obsessed
with uh we were obsessed with the story
before uh it was it was made into the
show crazy story we started watching it
yeah and
uh i mean why am i saying we as if like
i've started watching it and then it's
by the way shauna rhymes can i just be a
dork and that must be a trip
i'm um
i live in chandlerland now
how wild is that it's crazy like you
have a different kind of health
insurance it feels like a different
level yeah it's it's pretty cool i mean
it's just she is somebody who has
created
several iconic shows that have run
forever you know what i mean um and now
what's your master class and it is
fascinating is it she's just she's just
yeah
she's a badass she's just a badass i
don't know how to describe it like i and
two different things i read the script
first
and like i i keep saying this but the
action you know usually it's like he
walks in the door sets down his bag
whatever
her action is like the most fun thing
you can read so she's writing for
the reader
wow on top of writing for the viewer
usually stage direction is like boring
because like yeah because just get to it
just she's never not writing exactly
well yeah exactly and it's fun and like
it's like the most fun script i've ever
read um and then they were like hey it's
just gonna be a meeting it wasn't like
an audition it was just like come in and
sit down
and i kind of talked with
the people at the top of her company
with her in the room
they were kind of like so what do you
went to where you from da da da and then
like she was kind of like listening to
the answers and stuff and
not like a
fucking
you know uh
like uh
what's his name from um
yeah not like that but just kind of like
i think she might not be super outgoing
right so she has the people who were
very outgoing that work for her company
yeah or she's like i don't have to do
that i'm just gonna but she's in the
room so that's so i just but anyway um
and then we talked a little bit about
chicago and i guess you'd she'd seen me
on different shows and was like
let's i think i left and then found out
that i got it that's interesting because
it almost was like not a personality
audition but i think that like really
great creators sometimes you're like i
just want to cast someone that isn't
like like that has the essence that i
want that i want to write for there's a
lot of pressure that comes with
auditioning because you're like
i gotta do it the way that they
want it yeah and you're like what is
that and sometimes you take a swing and
you're i don't even know what that is
because they saw five people before you
do it poorly by the time
uh random labyrinth thing again i
watched jennifer connolly's audition for
labyrinth a lot
because she does it's on youtube she
does very little you have no power over
me and you're like wow
he doesn't i'm a scientologist now um is
she no no i just
where is she by the way she's
around she's with um remember her in a
beautiful mind remember how amazing that
performance was
what what'd she do in a beautiful mind
he was crunching the numbers where's she
but she was a member there was a scene
she's also a mathematician
i don't remember but she tried to have
sex with him and his medication made it
so she couldn't get he couldn't get an
erection or something and she like went
in the bathroom and like smashed the
mirror because she was so frustrated
chills oh yeah just masturbate
he couldn't because he was out of
medication
i've not finished inventing anna uh
uh
and
had you been a fan of that like did you
know about the story before
i knew about it but i wasn't like up on
it you know i mean i just heard heard
and you're like someone pretended to be
like you're like that's every girl in
hollywood a coffee bean yeah kind of um
no i was just like i had heard about it
but i didn't know about it i didn't know
like the aftermath about like or i
didn't know about the woman who
had like paid for the vacation and all
that i just heard about the her trying
to scam people
into funding the art
clubhouse fascinating yeah um but it's
crazy um and then going to like table
reads and watching the way that they
told the story seeing every script and
like it's so well constructed yeah it's
a lot of moving pieces where i'm just
like i'm a writer and i don't know how
they fucking did all that because like
so many characters so many stories so
many like
um
you know people that you want to flesh
out so that they don't seem like
two-dimensional you know what i mean but
teasing it out in a way where it's not
like it's
yeah it's it's so nothing feels
extraneous and it's yeah i know like
watch i love watching shows like that
and just being like humbled of like this
feels like
a 2 a.m adderall note card nightmare
right and then by the way uh we started
filming that before the pandemic you
guys the pandemic
um
and then we have endemic that's true
true should we get into it sorry hashtag
i don't know we're in a simulation um so
started it before that
then and it was gonna be a 10 episode
thing and then they turned it into nine
because we had to like
get people done before like hard outs or
whatever
um
and so they had to like rewrite a bunch
of scripts that
were like they had to take that 10th
episode and go okay fuck now we need to
pull that stuff and we can maybe bury
that here in this episode and like
that kind of like
jenga or like puzzle like rearrange like
rubik's cube yeah
i would have blown my brains out and a
lot of it is probably her and post or
whoever in post going like you know
they're i am also fascinated by uh what
happens in post because a lot of times
you're like uh right we don't need that
scene or this is actually i'd rather
watch the scene after i already know
this person a little better like i'm
just obsessed with that there is a scene
where this game they took out so my my
character is like the the husband of the
investigative journalist was trying to
get to the bottom of this whole scandal
right pun intended uh shonda lam
and uh you were laughing at my jokes
before by the way that was
that way it just took me a second okay i
was so engrossed with you and
uh
well i just oh that that you played the
husband of the uh anna chumps character
i'm like the everyone keeps being like
you're the nicest husband in the world
like
she was like crazy for what she was
doing and i'm like oh whatever um but
there was a moment in the scene where
it's like a role reversal like your wife
in real life is you in this show and
you're anna yes actually i'll get into
how similar my wife is to anna clumsy's
character uh it was like very strange
she even had the same earrings like anna
klumsky's character
wore the same exact earrings that my
real-life wife was your real-life wife
when she goes on runs she's actually
just like invest like spying on people i
don't know something's up um but they
cut um a little bit of a scene where i'm
like a little more stern with her about
like
what i expect from her as the future
mother is my of my child right
and so like
i'm standing in the doorway and then i
come and i sit down
and then she has like a thing where
she's talking and then when it cuts back
to me i'm standing up again and i was
like
oh fuck like they just took out the
middle of that scene took the other
thing i said from the beginning of the
scene and put it back there
and turned it into less of a
this husband's being kind of a dickhead
right now and they probably couldn't
reshoot it because of pandemic well they
didn't need to reshoot it yeah like they
like they
you know you just edit it yeah um well
now you just look like spider-man you
just like fly across the room it worked
yeah i'm i'm the only one who noticed
because i was there on the deck you know
what i mean but it was also like
like you know how actors are always like
what's my motivation for like going over
there i just need a reason why do i go
the lighting's good
right but you're like we need we need
movement something um
so like there's no reason for me to be
back at the door or to have sat down for
that moment right um but it is like the
magic of editing um okay
um i love you i end these super
awkwardly um uh inventing ana's on
netflix um and it is riveting and is not
going to lecture you on how to vote um
i mean i'm sure you've seen all i mean
your everything you do is amazing game
over man is one of my favorite like i
just love watching comedy that's funny
um and then this is important which also
also how do you pronounce important
how do i say it yeah
important
important
some people say important how do you
pronounce
interest interesting
interesting
i don't say interesting it's interesting
it someone corrected me recently i say
interesting yeah and someone's like it's
interesting yeah but you know what i
have heard a lot lately and i'm i'm not
okay with comfortability
i've never even heard that word people
are saying it all that's not a word
people are saying it's not a word but
people are saying
like uh this mattress has a lot of
comfortability and yeah these shoes a
lot of comfortability and i'm like
what not that's like startup people like
dumb startup people that make up just
fake vernacular it's like when when uh i
was in writer's rooms like when i first
started everyone was saying meta but
they didn't know what they were saying
it was like that joke is so meta ever
that's so meta and it was again i found
i was like what does that mean and no
one could tell me
yeah it's like people use the word
random for just everything i hate
buzzwords as well
did you ever hear about our well john
acquaintance was the person space is a
big one like what like i feel like you
should be doing something in this space
oh wait but have you heard um as you're
decorating your house like i think this
creates a nice moment i like this moment
here and i'm like i like that cut it out
is that weight is that john john
quaintons no no no we we as we were
doing stuff at our house the deck
speaking of words i can't pronounce
there's a this we feel like this is a
nice moment at this moment and then i
was like
uh hey how do you feel about this over
here would that be a good moment and
they were like
synergy was happening for a minute yeah
i was gonna say
words that people use that drive me
crazy like when you first use them great
yeah but then when they get kind of
handed down
it's like a game of telephone and people
don't know what the fuck it means that's
right and we have yes we're talking to
you hollywood executives we had a
whiteboard um at workaholics that was
like jokes we don't want writers to put
in scripts
uh like clams
like um uh uh
hey unders that's an ugly shirt did i
just say that out loud yes so that's on
the whiteboard yes and so john
acquaintance
took pictures of it and like tweeted it
and then we got a bunch of shit from
people like oh yeah you're not allowed
to make certain jokes who are you guys
the kings of comic or whatever or just
things that have been done so many times
it's to me i'm like if you're a paid
writer like a professional mm-hmm come
up with new jokes
nailed it hate that shit don't write or
if you want to do don't write i just
throw up in my mouth a little bit yeah
cause that's that belongs to christine
taylor from dodgeball did you guys call
it a clam
like it's like a clam clam
so what's funny about like writer terms
yeah is we also never use them because
none of us were writers oh god so like
when the harvard boys came in they were
like yeah it's like a turnaround or like
a yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
pitch we're like yeah don't do that just
like speak like
make it a new thing okay just and then
so
because uh uh and this is the one that
drove me the most nuts is like if
someone walks into a scene
and they go like hey emily nice uh uh um
this is a horrible one you should ever
do like cher wants her shirt back or
whatever that fucking like it's a street
joke basically and then that someone
would come in five minutes later and and
go hey cher wants her shirt back it was
like a call back but like like there's
no way two people will make the same
fucking shitty joke like i hate that
shit it's like a lazy
callback that isn't even a callback and
the like the the danger you get in by
calling out jokes is that people are
like well what jokes do you do that are
funny
so you're like all right fuck it
whatever but
what we would say is let's just not put
a joke there it doesn't need a joke if
there's like a joke that everybody knows
and like your aunt says who's not a
comedian yeah
don't put it in like a professional
script with your name on it yeah yeah i
mean like unless you're doing a play on
it in a way of course where you know
it's like
you're doing it on purpose like we were
going to do an entire teaser i think
that just lined up all of the jokes but
then we were like people are going to
love it funny people are going to love
it they love it well also not everyone
is commenting nerds the way we are and
you know what i mean and a lot of people
are like i just got home from my
construction job i don't really care if
this has been done before i'm just
trying to laugh that's true and and i
think people enjoy
hearing jokes that they make mm-hmm did
i mean like i think people want to hear
that i make that kind of joke at work
and now anders just made it yeah like i
must be nailed it belongs to
what's his name nathan not nathan uh for
you no um
it was from the commercial starring uh
is nicole byers melissa mccarthy's
husband who directed
ben falcone thank you
uh he's the guy who said nailed it
and now everyone says it like 10 years
later right but that's his don't put
that in the screen aziz ansari's
character in
parks and rec is making corny jokes on
purpose that's a different thing exactly
but guess what yeah
nobody knows that yeah right people
don't know that people it is like uh
that's what she said
that's what we're talking about right
and now what he said but do you see what
they did but that's what she said they
made it like
this whole thing on the office right
because it was corny but then they were
like
we're gonna make it
bigger than what it is right and this is
a lot uh last thing one thing that is
i'll decide what's left
like a writer's room thing that actually
is maybe worth sharing that i think you
might like a nakamura
is like when in multicam you know this
obviously like you do these run-throughs
so it's like like you're putting on a
play for everybody
and uh callbacks are always really funny
if it's done well they can be like
surprising and smart and the audience
feels in on it and whatever and but
if you're
the biscuits
and then there's some thrilling fun
callback right but a nakamura is when
you do like three or four callbacks
throughout the show that is based on
like the fir the first joke has to be
funny for the callbacks to hit yeah yeah
and how if you have a nakamura that's
like who burnt the toast right and
that's biscuits it's funny the biscuits
because it's a b and a b
sorry
that b sound um uh who burnt the
biscuits and um see this is why your
show went for seven years
um uh who birthed the biscuits and it
bombs the first time it was said right
and you have three more callbacks coming
to it and you're like oh who's nakamura
though nakamura was i think in family
top i think it was on family ties they
had a joke that was something nakamura
and then it bombed the first scene and
then you have three more callbacks
coming and you're just like oh fuck like
the first one didn't hit not gonna be
funny
uh uh
so yeah so that like when you're like oh
fuck yeah if that bombed now we're all
just sitting here dreading the three
callbacks that are in a bomb in front of
network executives my least favorite
that people would be like they'd be like
um if there's two jokes and it kind of
one cancels the other one out and they
go yeah it's kind of a hat on a hat
and i'd always go
do you know what's really funny
a guy wearing a hat
and then one of the rastafarian ones
with the fake dreadlocks love this one
when there's a hat on a hat never been
funny
it's actually the worst if it's the same
exact cause it's just two lakers hats on
like the that's sherlock holm style
right
yeah don't kill the lily it's too much
icing on the cake who doesn't like a lot
of icing on a cake killed the lily don't
kill the lily
see this is what i'm talking about
unacceptable we're just like huh
like just say don't make two jokes or
just pitch a better job no room for two
jokes we'll also just pitch a better
joke yeah like two hats
i love you what a retreat thank you for
doing this thank you for having me it's
always good to see you what a dream it
was a
fun to drive out here
you we do live comically far away yep
yep i'm sorry but when you come all the
way down because my horse is near you
so i'm actually yeah and my boyfriend
works and lives and passes do you have
animals no okay my wife became allergic
to animals in her 20s
kind of a bummer yeah because we thought
we would be like the family that had
like two boxers and then like she grew
up with cats like she's she's bummed
i would love nothing more why not
because it's still it's like the dander
or like the saliva the saliva yeah
that's right it's not even the hair
and then just putting that hairless cat
right on my belly just feeling the heat
between us
you know what i mean
that's what i want
do you have to make eye contact with me
quillest you do this bitch what's fine
is that now i just do that with my
children that's fine i go clothes off
curl up on daddy's belly
we're gonna watch part of the
interruption together
and then you get a boner and you're like
pardon that interruption
[Laughter]
oh my god aunder's home what a dream i
love you don't write elephants i am
these super awkwardly all right and my
phone is dead
[Music]
six
[Applause]